يبدو أن الولايات المتحدة في عهد الرئيس ترامب
تضع كل بيضها في هذه السلة السعودية في
الوقت الحالي فيما يتعلق
بأمن الشرق الأوسط وسياسة الشرق الأوسط
وقلت أنك تشعر أنهم
لم يثبتوا أنهم
حلفاء عسكريون موثوقون أو أكفاء وأنهم  هو
نفسه لا يبدو أنه مستعد بشكل كبير
بشكل جيد ، نعم ، سيقول السعوديون
باستمرار أنك تعرف
شيئًا رائعًا أن يكون لديهم أصدقاء
وحلفاء ومن الجيد أن يكون لديهم
أصدقاء وحلفاء ولكن أولاً وقبل كل شيء النفط
ليس كذلك  ما كان عليه في السابق على الإطلاق ، أنا
أقدر أنهم يشترون أذرعنا ولكن من الناحية
الواقعية ليس لديهم خيار آخر
ويدفعون مقابلهم ونمنحهم هذه
الصفقة ، إنها صفقة لا تساوي شيئًا
بالنسبة لنا وعندما يتعلق الأمر
بسؤالنا  عليهم أن يفعلوا شيئًا ما كشريك
، يؤسفني أن أقول إنهم لم يأتوا ،
على سبيل المثال ، سألت محمد بن
سلمان أم أنني التقيت عدة مرات
والعديد من المحادثات معه
وحاولت الحصول على علاقة عمل جيدة.
هل سيفعل شيئًا
حيال داعش ولم يفعلوا أبدًا أي شيء
بشأن داعش بدلاً من ذلك ، إذا كنت تتذكر
أنهم أعلنوا تحالفًا يومًا ما
دون إخبار أي شخص آخر في
العالم الإسلامي بأنهم بدأوا
تحالفًا إسلاميًا وكانت فكرة جيدة
ولكن هذا كان جاهزًا  هدف إطلاق النار نوع من
المبادرة ولذا فإن أداؤهم
لم يكن دائمًا كما يقترحون